je vais me tourner d'abord vers florian
parce que c'est vrai qu'il a pris tout
le monde à contre-pied on s'attendait
tous à une allocution
demain soir et non il va faire ça dans
la pqr et derrière ils tweetent au
calendrier
c'est ça c'est incroyable c'est nouveau
la communication oui en tout cas c'est
un bon choix du président de la
république en choisissant de s'adresser
à la pqr il fait le choix d'abord de
l'audience avec la pqr elle est plus lu
en france que la pqn la presse
quotidienne nationale ça le prêt sera
t'il regionnal impression pqr oui c'est
le premier moyen national de
l'information des français mais il faut
aussi revenir sur le fait que au fond
c'est aussi une stratégie de
communication politique réchauffer parce
que en mai 2019 avant les élections
européennes emmanuel macron il avait
déjà choisi deux choisit de faim de
s'adresser à la presse quotidienne
régionale pour parler aux français
il ya une relation entre emmanuel macron
et la pqr qu'une relation du je t'aime
moi non plus elle a été très difficile
notamment mai 2019
parce qu'il avait exigé de relire
l'interview est ce qu avait refusé les
journalistes considérant que ce n'était
pas une pratique acceptable s'il choisit
aujourd'hui de s'adresser à la pqr s'est
semble-t-il pour montrer qu'il est
proche des réalités du terrain et
s'adresser d'abord aux élus locaux qui
chérissent leur presse quotidienne
régionale
moi j'y vois une difficulté majeure
c'est que il n'adapte pas ce message aux
réalités des territoires bretons
auvergnat et c'est quand on prétend
s'adresser à la pqr c'est d'abord
normalement pour adapter les messages à
la cible ici on ne fait pas mais ça je
trouve que c'est un défaut qui pourrait
être reproché à cette stratégie de
communication politique
sinon comment ça a été perçu moi j'ai
trouvé que ça a été plutôt bien perçue
par par allal public par les français
j'ai trouvé voilà si j'ai en a qui ont
dit ça change un peu de le voir à la
télé et c'est vrai que à un moment est
ce qu'on le voit on l'a pas trop vu à la
télé donc peut-être qu'il va faire que
ses apparitions vont être plus espacées
vous avez raison cyril non seulement le
président de la république a trop
s'exprimer
il avait une difficulté c'est que sa
parole elle était diluée sessad en plein
d'incertitudes
ils étaient obligés de
engagé comme ils s'engagent l'a
d'ailleurs sur une cinquantaine de dates
dont il est en quelque sorte prisonnier
c'est pour ça que vous avez pu dire au
début que on sait que ces dates seront
tenues elles sont rendues publiques et
elles servent au fond d'horizon à tous
les français qui connaissait à ne plus
accepter socialement la série de
contraintes qui peut être c'est quoi
c'est cesser ses conseils aux
communications c'est qu'ils y ont dit là
à mon avis à ce niveau là il ya des
échéances qui arrivent y aller il ya les
vacances car il ya beaucoup de français
qui se demandent ce qu'ils vont faire
il ya des restaurateurs qui n'en peuvent
plus qui sont au bout de leur vie il ya
des gens dans l'événementiel aussi ce
qu'ils ont dit maintenant président il
faut un calendrier clair on voit là on
dit aux français ce qu'on va faire sur
le prochain mois pour les rassurer pour
essayer voilà de leur donner un petit
peu d'espoir moi c'est aujourd'hui vous
balader dans les rues de paris
c'est vrai que vous voyez même moi ça
m'a fait plaisir j'ai vu plein de
restaurateurs commencé à nettoyer les
terrains à sortir le matériel
ce secteur dès qu'ils commencent à
réembaucher et ça bon ça fait ça fait
quand même du bien
1 et c'était pour d'autres données
morale aussi un peu oui on sait qu'on a
dit au président de la république qu'il
fallait à la fois reprendre en main le
tempo de l'agenda médiatique et c'est
pour ça qu'il a surpris tout le monde
il a voulu surprendre et reprendre en
main le cours des annonces
et puis il a voulu surtout redonner la
lisibilité à sa stratégie sa stratégie
on la connaît désormais aller simple
elle est qu'il ne se cale pas sur le
conseil scientifique qui semblait
jusque-là être le véritable gouvernement
de la france
ici le président il prend un risque il
est audacieux il dit quoi qu'il arrive
quel que soit le niveau au fond de
contamination et bien voilà quelle sera
ma stratégie ça permet de rassurer les
acteurs économiques de donner un espoir
aux français
et ça c'est évidemment pour lui une
bonne chose alors un espoir en français
oui mais bruno bégard ban chef du
service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière
on va revoir l'agenda vous allez nous
dire si vous convient cet agenda parce
que c'est mon ami n'ont rien le
principal intéressé
alors ils démarrent d'une longue
démarche directe par la deuxième et à
pouvoir démarrer par l'étape une entrée
intéressante et à une 3 mai 2021
couvre-feu maintenu fin de l'attestation
en journée d ouverture des collèges et
lycées en 2011 levée des restrictions
pour les déplacements interrégionaux
ensuite et
2 c on est à l'étape de maintenant
couvre-feu décalé à 21h il avait dit un
mois y avait laissé glisser une petite
phrase il avait dit on va décaler le
couvre feu
donc voilà ce sera à 21h dès le 19 mai
réouverture des commerces des commerces
et des terrasses table de six personnes
max ça fait plaisir à beaucoup de monde
ouverture des musées cinémas théâtres
salles de spectacles 800 l'intérieur
1000 à l'extérieur
rouverture établissements sportifs en
plein air étape 3 couvre-feu à 23h à
partir du 9 juin réouverture des cafés
et restaurants possibilité d'accueillir
jusqu'à 5000 personnes dans un lieu de
culture établissements sportifs
réouverture des salles de sport
accueille des touristes étrangers avec
pas sanitaires et top4 fin du couvre-feu
générale le 30 juin fin des limites de
jauge pour les établissements recevant
du public possibilité d'accéder à tout
événement rassemblant plus de 1000
personnes
les discothèques restent fermés ça va
pas faire plaisir à roger le mec de
delphi d'un coup alors docteur ce qu'on
est ce qu'il va vous ce calendrier
oui je crois que je trouve assez
réaliste d'accord et progressif
la prise de risque me paraît assez
faible l'épidémie régresse bien alors
certes la grèce bien ou pas vrai grèce
bien ce que certains trois fois plus
lentement que ce que nous a observé en
mars avril 2020 d'accord mais ça
régresse et désormais même nous avons
passé le pic du nombre de patients admis
en réanimation et l'hôpital qui commence
à diminuer très lentement mais casillas
et ça c'est la question principale on se
dit est ce que c'est le bon timing et ce
qui fige et voilà le timing à ce qui
nous donne là le calendrier c'est la
courbe et là vous me dites que la courbe
elle est plutôt on était sur un plateau
ça commence à s'atténuer alors c'est
surtout ce qui est important c'est la
régression de l'incidence des nouveaux
cas de contamination d'alcool
malheureusement la situation en
réanimation reflète en fait aujourd'hui
ce qui s'est passé il ya trois semaines
ne reflète pas ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est d'ailleurs la baisse en
animation va se faire extrêmement
lentement par contre l'épidémie régresse
bien et donc effectivement on se
permette d'ouvrir progressivement mais
c'est vrai qu'il faut savoir qu'au 15
mai qui est la date principal
malheureusement on ne sera pas au 5000
nouveaux
au cas de contamination par jour qui est
le seuil qui permet d'appliquer de façon
très sera on sera plus efficace la
strate le dessus voilà on sera 15000
très probable donc en trois fois pour la
3e fois de plus mais c'est là où il ya
un espoir important par rapport à la
situation d'avant c'est à dire à ce
moment là d'abord il fera plus chaud
d'accord qu'on va avoir tendance à
sortir de chez soi à vivre à l'extérieur
ouvrit de la fenêtre puis fabriqué piste
ira bien c'est ça le point important
c'est la vaccination va progresser ça
est donc désormais très probablement à
partir à mon humble avis je l'admets la
vaccination s'ouvrir à la totalité de la
population est mis sur sa le président
il se dit bien sûr bien sûr
voilà c'est ça qui va nous permettre de
réussir le déconfinement alors fabriqué
visio je vous sent bouillir et 6 passes
nous sommes aimerait vous serez mon
lacet je crois effectivement si vous
voulez c'est intéressant ce que vous
dites je suis là c'est ouais je pense
que c'est vrai je suis là c'est la même
situation de tous les français je suis
passé par la phase de colère et puis
maintenant je passe par la phase de
résignation on se fout de notre gueule
et je l'accepté
1 c'est ça ouais c'est ça arrive à un
moment donné vous savez je pense qu'il
ya aussi dynamique de résignation moi je
m'en fous et la limite au bout d'un
moment comme vous le dites moi je monte
à cheval ça rien perturbé de mon
activité je monte à cheval je fais
télétravail depuis tout le temps entre
les etats-unis la france le mans fou et
à ce qui arrive à un moment donné
chercher une logique dans cette histoire
c'est prendre le risque de devenir fou
dingue et g j'accepte pas ce risque
parce que concrètement c'est du cinéma
tout ça c'est là bien cinéma mais enfin
je veux dire très réfléchie sont deux
minutes je dire les promesses vont être
tenues j'entends çà et là
ouï dire les promesses votre tenue donc
si je comprends bien
si demain ce que je n'espère pas nous
avons une reprise épidémique jr majeur
ce que j'espère évidemment pas nous
allons quand même continuer à maintenir
des mesures c'est ça qu'on est en train
de me dire je croyais que ce qui faisait
la dynamique
les décisions que nous prenions c'était
précisément la courbe épidémique ça et
que donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
dire quoi qu'il en soit les engagements
seront tenus
bah je crois qu'on veut dire qu'en
réalité ça dépend de la dynamique
épidémique ou alors justement ce que
vous dites fabrice parce que certaines
séries ce que dit fabrice quand même
c'est que je me rappelle d'une
allocution du président oui disait il
faut passer en dessous des 100 jimmy cas
de contamination par jour aujourd'hui
là il nous l'avait dit au 15 mai on sera
à 15000 donc je comprends qu'il ya des
français qui se disent je comprends pas
il ya trois mois où il ya deux mois on
nous dit il faut qu'on passe en tout
sinon on n'arrivera pas à des confiné et
là on nous dit on ne dit que 15000 tout
le monde est dehors et on l'oublié autre
chose
les gens me disent ils c'est très chaud
je vais mieux je sais juste
effectivement tout le monde met pas
dehors au 15 mai fait un certain nombre
de mesures sont toujours en place et
notamment le couvre-feu qui est le plus
important à dakar m de contenir au caire
progression des choses à m'excuser moi
je veux excuser moi ça je peux pas le
laisser dire docteur je veux dire
pardonnez moi avant doit déjà discuté
ici plein de fois mais vous pouvez pas
aujourd'hui aux français
dire que le couvre-feu j'ai alors qu'on
sort d'un mois de confinement que le
couvre-feu est celui qui va changer la
donne
enfin restons sérieux s'il vous plaît
j'avais passé du couvre-feu à 19h à 21h
va changer la donne avez-vous le moins
avez vous la moindre étude sur la
question des études un peu sérieuses sur
la question
je veux bien en débattre je suis un
homme du débat je viens en disant
vraiment résigné vous non mais si vous
voulez un moment donné on prend les
français pour des cons je dire ça suffit
quoi je veux dire c'est comme le coût du
masque en extérieur on attend quoi
c'était le premier à l'enlever yann
galut maire de bourges et c'est vrai que
vous avez fait un gros coup là dessus
parce que ya plein de gens qui vous
suivent
on entend de plus en plus de gens qui
disent que le masque extérieur vous êtes
d'accord avec ça il n'a pas besoin de le
mettre aujourd'hui enfin bon alors on
continue à le mettre
est ce qu'on continue à prendre des
amendes d'ailleurs sur le mais qui sait
pas où on doit le mettre en 35 ans alors
vous non mais il faut regarder comment
ça s'est passé il ya dix la france à des
territoires complètement différent vous
l'avez dit vous-même
il se trouve qu'à bourges l'évolution de
l'épidémie était en baisse constante on
est deux fois on a deux fois moins de
cas qu'à paris ou en région parisienne
et si vous voulez avec le préfet du cher
on a eu un échange et donc il a été
décidé qu'on l'enlevait le masque à
bourges alors qu'il existait depuis
depuis plusieurs mois et donc c'est ça
il faut s'adapter au territoire mais
pour revenir au débat calendrier au
calendrier aujourd'hui
moi ce que je constate et je ne suis pas
un soutien spécial de monsieur macron
c'est que avec ses voisins
là je suis je suis au ps je suis de
gauche mais là dessus je vais vous dire
quelque chose c'est que il redonne un
espoir il redonne une perspective il
donne un calendrier qui paraît au
premier abord crédible et progressif
moi j'en peux plus genre tous les jours
tous les jours je suis dans les rues de
bourges je discute avec ma population
avec mes habitants ils ont peuvent plus
en plus morales sont à bout il souhaite
m'en voulais vous dire aux gens que et
l'histoire elle date quand même depuis
de l'upi mois novembre et aux nouveaux
cdd stoppant deux mamans une fois on met
le couvre-feu ou une forme et
confinement il faut on dit ça mais c'est
sarah et c est moi et avec en plus d
incompréhension totale
moi je suis intervenu pour redemander en
janvier que le lieu culturel ouvre
pourquoi j'ai fait ça cyril parce que
j'ai la chance d'avoir une petite fille
de 9 ans qui s'appelle l'ena elle avait
besoin de basket au mois de janvier
d'accord je vais à décathlon dans une
grande surface c'était plein à craquer
il y avait du monde et je ne peux pas
l'amener au musée je ne peux pas
l'amener au théâtre alors que lui c'est
parce que les biens culturels et aient
été fermées donc ciblé au bout d'un
moment aussi les français ne comprennent
pas certaines décisions de classe qui
est très important c'est quoi c'est de
dire voilà on a ce calendrier on va y
aller progressivement
on s'y tient moi je suis très attentif à
ce que vous avez dit cher docteur c'est
on a un taux de reproduction qui est
passé en dessous
et moi je vois aussi à l'hôpital de
bourges en réanimation il ya moins de
lits occupés en lits d'hospitalisation
classique il ya moins de lits donc j'ai
l'espoir dans quelle partie de ces gens
qui se disent ça fait des mois et des
mois qu'on subit ça on l'accepté les
berruyers l'on accepté les habitants de
bourges comme d'ailleurs l'accepter mais
aujourd'hui je les sens très tendue mais
par rapport à cette situation là je peux
dire sur ce que dit yann galut je ne
demandais pas aux chroniqueurs ce qu'ils
auront ce que j'ai l'impression que les
annonces aussi du chef de l'état
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit le conseil
scientifique il a un petit peu mis de
côté je pense qu'il faut il a plus pensé
au moral des français a relancé un petit
peu la machine et à se dire bon les
chiffres ils sont pas fous mais il faut
relancer la machine
il faut que les français reprennent
espoir est que l'économie reprenne
je pense qu'il a
c'est ça et je vois aujourd'hui il ya
quand même un élan d'espoir autour de ça
moi la seule petite crainte que j'ai je
vous le dis c'est que quand on a un
calendrier comme ça on sait ce qui se
passe couvre-feu 19 mai étape 2 ça va
être dans la tête de tout le monde c'est
fini c'est normal c'est le petit
problème à chaque fois là dedans et
c'est vrai c'est souvent comme ça dans
la tête de tout le monde on dit ah t'as
vu le 19 mai ça y est ouverture des
musées des cinémas des théâtres et la
serbie
c'est fini c'est ça on a dans notre tête
aujourd'hui l'épidémie avec ses annonces
je suis le maire elle est terminée et
moi je trouve que c'est très compliqué
même ce que vous avez fait dans notre
commune
parce que ça veut dire aux français
finalement depuis des mois on galérait
mais c'était pas si important que ça et
là excusez moi il s'en rendre compte le
gouvernement ils ont même mis des freins
d'urgence dans certains départements des
gens se disent ah mais oui en disant oh
là là attention parce que dans des zones
en région parisienne par exemple c'est
tellement fort encore la circulation du
virus que qu'est ce qu'on a fait que ce
calendrier eux mêmes ils se disent on a
agi pour des raisons politiques
électorales qu'est ce qu'on a fait la
durée fait des français c'est fini les
lui les mines voilier donges loire qu'on
soit pédagogique tous bah oui parce que
c'est par étapes
il va aussi falloir qu'on conçoit en
première ligne pour expliquer mais vous
savez moi je moi je rejoins aussi votre
vous savez c'est pas facile
non c'est facile pour personne on est on
est sur une ligne de crête permanente
est-ce que je prend la bonne décision
est-ce que je ne la prends pas comment
on fonctionne mais aujourd'hui on est
arrivé à un taux d'acceptabilité à mon
avis qui est proche de zéro moi je vois
m aujourd'hui nous avons nos bailleurs
ont normalement on devrait mettre dans
certains endroits des dizaines d'amande
et voilà on arrivait à un moment donné
où il fallait donner des perspectives
mais je vous rejoins aussi sur le fait
qu'il va falloir continuer à expliquer
que c'est par étapes
oui accompagner ceux des confinement et
vous avez raison il faut pas que ça soit
la fête alors totalement convaincu vous
n'êtes pas convaincu j'ai toujours été
très légaliste et là je ne comprends pas
ce calendrier je comprends pas non plus
d'ailleurs la presse écrite l'histoire
de la presse écrite quotidienne mais je
trouve ce calendrier est pas logique par
rapport à ce que les manuels macro avait
lui même déclaré je le trouve confus
folk une aisée sur le frigo un d antan
alors là oui alors là je suis un oui
lors la scène 19 heures
à ces 21 heures je trouve ça pas clair
douleur nous les territoires parce
qu'effectivement pas de nous bassiner en
disant que certains territoires sont
plus à risque que d'autres hélas une
espèce de trou mais journal samedi
région alors juste jambes les divisions
je vois que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
que dit isabelle mais c'est intéressant
parce que finalement dit oui ça me
ferait plaisir
la véritable problématique froid calais
elle est bien résumé c'est à dire qu'en
fait ce qu'on a besoin aussi cette
clarté et de lisibilité
voilà j'ai critiqué ouvertement certains
choix
maintenant je suis pas la tête de l'état
assis ses choix en fait sont faits il
faut les assumer
mais ou alors si vous les assumez pas il
faut expliquer pourquoi vous les assumez
pas mais aujourd'hui si vous voulez il
ya quand même une grande confusion
c'est que un an plus tard la question
que je me pose moi ok on est tous
contents d'aller ouvrir mais attention
un petit progressivement et en octobre
on fait quoi on se prépare pour octobre
ou pas du tout avec ça ce que à un
moment donné c'est ça la question est-ce
que c'était pire ennemi est finie alors
là on a vu on a vu qu'il y avait un cas
de variants indien premier cas en france
est-ce qu'il faut s'en inquiéter bruno
parce que c'est vrai que vous avez vous
êtes chefs de service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière
est-ce que c'est inquiétant j'ai vu
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui c'est à
dire ah ça c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
alors on va dire c'était tout à fait
attendu il faut pas imaginer que les
frontières peuvent empêcher l'entrée
d'un virus sur un territoire
donc c'est attendu maintenant
effectivement il faut ralentir la
progression de ce variant parce qu'il a
la possibilité éventuellement non prouvé
encore de pouvoir contaminé des
personnes même vacciné ça alors là où il
faut être un peu plus on va dire assurer
c'est que certes il
il est plus contagieux que la souche
habituel par contre il n'a pas davantage
comptable de contagiosité par rapport à
la sauce anglaise qui aujourd'hui
occupent le territoire
c'est 3 25% de prévalence donc en fait
il est très peu probable qu'il s'impose
par rapport à l'assemblée anglaise mais
ça parce qu'à chaque fois on le rappelle
un comme des virus et des cd bataille de
virus en fait il y en a un qui sort
vainqueur
voilà pour pour schématiser est a priori
le vario anglais sortirait vainqueur du
varions indien donc ce serait le vario
un dié gradés on va dire
l'anglais qui prédomine mais encore donc
voilà donc on serait dans la même gamme
mais pourquoi je vous pose cette
question c'est parce que quand on voit
un premier cas de variants indien on se
dit est ce que le calendrier va pas être
bousculé parce que si on voit ce qui se
passe pas tout ce que vous avez prévu et
que le variant indien de vire un
prépondérant est-ce que ça va pas
devenir problématique là le calendrier
est est-ce qu'il va pas falloir faire
machine arrière avec la question si vous
voulez - regard déjà des exemples
concrets là qui m'intrigue qui me
perturbe
on en parlait autrefois ici la question
des écoles ouais on a choisi de fermer
les écoles fallait-il fallait-il pas
j'en sais rien mais a priori si on
choisit de fermer les écoles c'est parce
qu'on considère qu' une raison de le
faire
un mois plus tard on ré ouvre les écoles
mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait du coup on a
indiqué martin krieger qu'on a nous a
interviewé ce matin qui est un type
spécialiste mondial des questions de
transmission qui vous dit
la transmission par aérosol elle est
majoritaire et que donc l'aération et
toutes les questions d'aération elles
sont au coeur du dispositif de lutte
contre l'épidémie qu'est ce qu'on a fait
est ce qu'on a mis en place des
dispositifs dans les rations des écoles
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les halls et les
élèves retournent à l'école de manière
seb est ce que est ce que est ce que
tout ça est prêt on a quand même
l'impression moment donné qu'on l'a
confiné sous la pression et qu'on des
contes film sous la pression moi je veux
dire je suis pas favorable le
confinement j'ai déjà dit ici mais pour
autant moi je veux bien mais à un moment
donné on a pris des mesures
il faut aller jusqu'au bout de ces
mesures est aujourd'hui peut-être que le
temps qui nous était offert on pouvait
l'utiliser à faire des choses et
peut-être qu'il n'est pas trop tard pour
les faire ces choses et enfin avec les
premiers de contamination parce que si
vous ouvrez les commerces mais vous
rêvez pas les problèmes d'aération les
problèmes de ventilation et de vous
expliquer pas aux gens comment se
contaminent on y encore dans deux ans
quoi mais moi j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
quand même une vraie préparation tout
cas moi je vois par exemple à bourges
les commerçants les restaurateurs se
prépare là où je vais vous avez raison
là vous avez raison c'est vrai que moi
ce que je reproche au gouvernement c'est
son manque d'anticipation et ils
n'oubliaient ne donne pas des lignes
claires pour se préparer
l'autre l'autre difficulté ça a été la
vaccination nous sur le terrain en tant
qu'élu on a galéré au niveau de la
vaccination de laval la vaccination
on avait des consignes différentes et
donc c'est vrai que là il faut aussi
avec ce calendrier de déconfinement où
je peux aussi vous rejoindre préparer la
rentrée parce que on a juste
l'impression que parce que à part été je
veux dire au 30 juin s'est pas terminée
comme c'est comme un des favoris
je suis tout à fait d'accord on redoute
tous les français c'est
le stop and go mais c'est exactement ça
alors là on va rouvrir les commerces de
19 tout le monde à dire avant où aller
on les ouvre on investit on repart on
fait des commandes et on vient de
l'apprendre en octobre on commence à
entendre des rumeurs de re confinement
et la sarre confie mais là on est
reparti et c'est la pire des choses
parce que papa c'est la pire des choses
aussi économiquement bien sombre les
petits commerces pour pour les
restaurateurs parce que ils
réinvestissent je vous le dis il ya
plein de gens qui disent ah ça y est on
va réembaucher
on est reparti et là ça repart on repart
à zéro
et ça c'est insupportable moralement
c'est insupportable économies matures
mais forcément c'est le truc c'est que
aujourd'hui le vrai là la vraie question
c'est la question de la vaccination
8 aujourd'hui qu'un variant indien karim
et qu'il peut contaminer des personnes
vaccinées
c'est vrai que là on se dit c'est une
histoire sans fin non non j'allais dire
d'abord il faut il faut rassurer sur
l'importance de la vaccination
aujourd'hui le le brillant indien ne
représente qu'un cas en france
le fait de traverser mais protège contre
la quasi totalité des souches qui cirait
les gaillards tout à fait donc il faut
absolument encourager la vaccination
d'ailleurs le variant indien va moins se
répandre lorsqu'il va rencontrer des
personnes vaccinées autour de lui
d'accord voilà donc évidemment vous avez
raison photo confiant je suis plutôt
confiant sur ce fait rien c'est au gap
oui sur le variant indien je suis plutôt
que ça on n'a pas de raison de
s'inquiéter non d'ailleurs même le ms ne
le considère pas comme un variante
inquiétant alors quand un bail et en
variants pour lequel il faut surveiller
d'accord guillaume genton vous je suis
assez étonné ou ce n'est pas convaincu
par le planning de des noms mais j'ai
toujours dit que les commerces allait
rouvrir le dit bernard faire les
boutiques est une formation qu'on est
devenu complètement fou en un an on est
en train de se réjouir parce que dans
deux mois on pourra peut-être sauf
situation sanitaire départemental
dégradées ne plus avoir de couvre-feu
aller au restaurant
moi ce que je retiens c'est qu'on est
obligé de se faire vacciner d'ailleurs
un passeport vaccinale on va encore evry
la paix des masques on pourra plus
voyager comme on veut il ya encore des
ddd des infrastructures pour lesquelles
ça ne va pas du tout bougé notamment les
discothèques les boîtes de nuit etc
donc pour moi c'est tout sauf un retour
à la vie normale on lui donne envie de
danser tout le temps envie d'amérique on
vivra plus jamais comme avant
il attendait mais moi attendait juste
moi ce qui me - ce qui est ce que me
disent aussi les gens mais pourquoi en
france ça se passe comme ça alors qu'il
ya cette situation d'angleterre ont
travaillé en israël par exemple ou dans
d'autres pays
et on a l'impression à ce que ce que je
constate c'est que on a l'impression
qu'en france on est en retard sur dans
plein de domaines mais nous accompagner
ou qui sont juste à côté des autres ont
réussi là où nous on en train d'échouer
mais donc je pense que ce calendrier il
a le mérite d'exister
il n'est sûrement pas parfait il a
sûrement plein de défis de demain car
nous donner leurs déboires en sachant
que cet espace là vous avez tout à fait
raison c'est pas c'est pas la porte
ouverte à tous et qu'il va falloir qu'on
va se traîner cette affaire pendant des
mois et des mois vous on va devoir
regarder ce que vous entendez le pape et
des mous oui le showcase à tous mes
coups par les matches on nous donne de
l'espoir
oui on est tous devenus fous là mais je
veux dire on donne de l'espoir
c'est au gouvernement merci genty
président de la république nous donner
de l'espoir moi j'aurais préféré qu'ils
nous donnent des solutions fecteau mais
me donne de l'espoir vous êtes tous
devenus fous à basculer dans le monde
d'après dans l'ère du post le poste
droit le poste sanitaire le poste aux
logiques on est dans le monde d'après un
président la république un gouvernement
n'est pas là pour nous de l'espoir est
là pour nous apporter des solutions et
aujourd'hui des solutions à moi j'en
vois pas il n'y a pas de solution de
lutte contre l'épidémie qu'elle n'a pas
il n'avait pas hier il n'aura pas demain
alors on va voir
alors à savoir ses téléspectateurs
fabrice qui est intime alors cédé 43 à
33 % oui non à 67%